mes chers collègues
alors monsieur le ministre il y a une
tradition dans cette délégation c'est le
démarrage à l'heure
voilà donc on a peut-être deux minutes
mais vous nous pardonnerez donc vraiment
au nom de nous tous je voudrais vous
adresser mais plus sincères et
chaleureux remerciements
pour cette rencontre ce matin alors je
vous prie
d'excuser les collègues qui ne peuvent
pas être là parce que certains groupes
politiques ont aujourd'hui
un séminaire et que donc beaucoup ont
regretté ne pas pouvoir être là mais
vous aurez grand nombre de questions et
l'intérêt alors échanger avec vous
monsieur le minis c'est essentiel parce
que vous êtes
vous vous avez un ministère extrêmement
important alors vous savez qu'ici on a
commis à Grémy Pointreau il n'y a pas
très longtemps un rapport sur la
simplification et nous avons pris une
fâcheuse habitude de compter le nombre
de mots
voilà parce que nous cultivons comme
vous nous invité à le faire pour
Lausanne la sobriété
également dans les mots et donc votre
décret d'application
est impressionnant puisqu'il comporte
près de 2000 mots
ceci veut dire la charge de votre
ministère le chant d'intervention
puisqu'on y parle naturellement
environnement on n'est pas le transport
on y parle et qui mentile logement
renouvellement urbain urbanisme voilà et
donc à cela s'ajoutent vos compétences
en matière de décentralisation vous
savez que c'est un sujet que le Sénat
affectionne particulièrement parce que
nous nous pensons que c'est un outil
d'efficacité vous avez dans vos
attributions la politique de
renforcement des responsabilités locales
donc nous sommes faits peut-être pour
nous entendre à condition qu'on y
rajoute responsabilité et liberté locale
monsieur le ministre vous parlez aussi
des métropoles des finances locales de
la solidarité financière entre les
territoires et vous avez la charge de
mettre en oeuvre la politique notamment
transition en matière de transition
écologique à l'égard des collectivités
donc vous comprenez
l'intérêt l'intérêt que nous portons à
cet échange alors nous ne couvrons
certainement pas au travers de nos
questions l'exhaustivité de vos
fonctions mais l'essentiel et je sais
que nous aurons l'occasion de vous
retrouver dans un format plus collectif
au Sénat bientôt grâce aux actes donc
nous allons essayer d'être sobre et
frugal puisque
c'est c'est la tendance et pour ma part
je parlerai de quelques sujets qui nous
tous alors naturellement on peut pas
s'empêcher de parler d'usage alors on
peut dire que c'est une obsession c'en
est une parce que je crois que vous le
savez bien monsieur le ministre les
mauvais esprits aurait tendance à faire
croire que le Sénat
vraiment
est une structure qui ne comprend rien à
l'environnement et au sauvetage de la
planète faux vous le savez bien la
qualité de l'esprit ordinateur fait
qu'on a très bien compris mais justement
parce qu'on l'a bien compris qu'on pense
qu'il faut le faire nous aimerions
pouvoir travailler avec vous sur des
modalités d'application qui soit
diversifiée qui soit intelligentes
pertinentes et donc moi j'aimerais d'une
manière
générale et simple sans anticiper les
débats que nous avons que vous nous
disiez si vous vous êtes positivement
attentif à la proposition de loi des du
Sénat ensuite à notre sujet qui vous
concerne au plus haut point c'est celui
de la norme parce que le zan est quand
même un exemple remarquable
d'injonction un peu contradictoire je
prends l'exemple de la mère du Croisic
c'est pas loin de chez vous le Croisic
sinon votre région qui me dit alors moi
la biodiversité le climat j'aime
beaucoup je veux aider on me dit en même
temps qu'il faut que je construise des
logements sociaux
je ne peux pas les construire parce
qu'il va me rester que les a 9 mm
caractère qui ne m'appartiennent pas
d'ailleurs et donc je ne vais pas
pouvoir répondre à une obligation que
l'État me fixe avec la construction de
logements sociaux à cause d'une autre
obligation qui est Lausanne mais on va
quand même maintenir
l'amande de l'amande que je mérite parce
que je construis pas de logements
sociaux donc monsieur le ministre
au-delà de la surcharge normative je
pense qu'on a une sorte un moment
d'absurdité et que l'excès de bien et le
plus grand ennemi de l'efficacité
ensuite
on aura sûrement des interrogations sur
les finances des collectivités locales
parce que là on a un peu des cas je
rappelle que les normes et les lois
produites entre 2017 et 2021 on produit
un surcoût de près de 2 milliards
d'euros pour les collectivités que la
norme allégée nous permettrait
d'optimiser les budgets et que tout le
monde est très intéressé sur le fond
vert il ne voudrions savoir s'il y aura
vraiment une gouvernance un peu
territoriale où les élus sont associés
moi je suis pas toujours critique
monsieur le ministre je voudrais dire
qu'hier en commission des lois nous
avons légiféré sur le tiers financement
qui est quelque chose d'exemplaire au
sens où c'est une solution qui en plus
fera l'objet
d'une expérimentation donc monsieur le
ministre nous avons
tous ces sujets avec le dernier don des
collègues par le beaucoup et on en a
parlé avec le directeur de l'anxiété
directeur de l'ADEME dans le cadre de la
réflexion qui conduit au Sénat sur la
décentralisation la déconcentration on a
un besoin énorme aujourd'hui
digne générer d'expertise auprès de nos
collectivités je vais prendre l'exemple
de la transition écologique je vous l'ai
dit hier les collectivités les avancent
elles avancent aussi vite que leurs
moyens leur permettent mais elles se
retrouvent aujourd'hui
victime en quelque sorte d'une image qui
fait que vous devez partout
avoir recours à certaines techniques qui
sont en matière de transition écologique
positif si vous le faites pas vous êtes
un peu culpabilisé alors même que je
pense exactement comme la loi il est
extrêmement important de mesurer la
pertinence des investissements que vous
allez faire en matière de transition
écologique par rapport à leur efficacité
et que il faut que les collectivités
notamment sans doute celles qui n'ont
pas d'ingénierie soit accompagnés pour
faire un vrai diagnostic une expert
avant d'aller engager des dépenses
considérables qui à un moment s'avérait
un peu disproportionné alors mon propos
est un peu catalogue à la Prévert mais
Prévert ne manquait pas de poésie alors
le mien peut-être un peu moins je ne
serai pas plus longue monsieur le
ministre
j'aurai une dernière question insolente
c'est quand même on a une idée au Sénat
comporte avec le corps rapporteur match
d'Arnaud c'est que dans le cadre de
cette ingénierie nous nous pensons qu'il
y a aussi une collection d'agences Adem
à NCT en rue anale tout ça s'est bien
compliqué peu visible et donc nous avons
une idée disruptive le Sénat peut l'être
monsieur le ministre pour confusionne
pas tout ça merci monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les
les sénateurs je vais vous dire mon
plaisir à 24 heures d'écart d'être à
nouveau dans cette salle
hier matin pour répondre à l'invitation
de la commission des lois et pour
défendre le principe du tiers
financement qui permet à la fois
d'accélérer sur la transition écologique
en tenant compte de la situation des
collectivités territoriales et ce matin
pour devant votre délégation répondre à
vos sujets de préoccupation
finalement je vais
je ne vais pas vous infliger un propos
introductif
d'abord parce que la précédente Gatel y
compris dans la manière dont elle vient
de présenter les sujets
à pointer le fait que le champ était
large et donc si je me lance de mon côté
dans un inventaire quelque soit les
grands auteurs que je pourrais invoquer
pour le faire le risque et de trop
insister sur des domaines qui ne vous
intéressent pas ou en tout cas pas
aujourd'hui et à l'inverse si je choisis
un ou deux thèmes pour rentrer dedans
alors que il ne correspond pas à vos
attentes on perdra un temps utile aux
échanges que nous pourrions avoir et
donc je préfère répondre à vos questions
plutôt que de faire une déclaration
liminaire qui consisterait à lister tous
les sujets sur lesquels on travaille je
vais juste me contenter de quelques
têtes de chapitres extrêmement succincte
et d'un ou deux éléments de réponse à la
présidente Françoise Gatel
la très grande originalité de ce
ministère c'est pour la première fois
d'expliquer que la cohésion des
territoires et la transition écologique
ça va ensemble et pour être précis que
non seulement c'est pas antinomique mais
que c'est une condition de réussite de
se préoccuper de la manière dont cette
transition on donne les clés aux élus
pour être capable de la conduire
et quand le ministre de la cohésion des
territoires dans son périmètre le
logement et les transports c'est aussi
un indicateur fort du besoin d'alliance
d'union sacrée entre les élus et l'État
sur ces sujets qui sont éminemment des
sujets de cohésion et dans le même temps
éminemment des sujets de transition
on alzane on aura l'occasion d'en parler
très bientôt
si vous souhaitez qu'on entre dans le
détail avant même la commission je le
ferai évidemment avec plaisir je serai
tenté de vous suggérer
de commencer par appliquer à vous-même
les conseils que vous pourriez nous
donner
en clair vous voulez moins de normes
faites en sorte que dans le texte
remanier on aille pas créer des
nouvelles instances qui vont rajouter
des heures de réunion aux élus et qui
risque de se traduire à la fin quelque
soit les idées louables avec lesquelles
on commence par des usines à gaz pour
lesquels là vous ne pourrez pas vous
abriter derrière le fait que ça a été
imposé par le gouvernement
la lecture que j'ai du texte tel qu'il
est proposé par le Sénat elle est
positive sur certains aspects il y a des
articles avec lesquels je me retrouve
elle est réservée sur d'autres dans
lequel on crée des mécanismes on
institutionnalise la conférence des
scottes qui rajoute entre guillemets une
couche on prévoit des dispositifs de
contrats à toutes les échelles qui vont
derrière devoir se décliner qui
donneront lieu à des décrets à des
précisions sur la manière dont on avance
et qui me semble ne pas être utile
enfin préserver les territoires ruraux
ne veut pas dire le faire de manière
aveugle et j'ai un point de désaccord
principal avec la proposition du Sénat
sur la garantie rurale je ne considère
pas que donner la même chose à tout le
monde ce soit la justice
c'est l'égalitarisme et ça n'est ni
l'équité ni le sens de ce qu'il faut
faire je plaide donc pour qu'au lieu de
donner un hectare par commune nous
puissions accorder une garantie rurale
de 1% du territoire artificialisé ce qui
permet de tenir compte de la taille des
communes et de pas se retrouver dans une
situation ou une commune de 50 habitants
se retrouverait avec la même garantie
qu'une commune de 3000 pour prendre deux
exemples volontairement opposés
je suis à votre disposition sur les
sujets financiers bien entendu dans un
contexte où on a beaucoup parlé finance
sur la fin de l'année 2023 et 2022 et
puis c'est toujours le jeu quand on est
dans les premières semaines de l'année
qui suit en se concentre moins sur les
questions financières alors que c'est
parfois le moment où on peut avoir
quelques éclairages intéressants sur la
façon dont la nécessité et même si ça
n'est que le 15 février
qu'on aura une vision un peu consolidée
de la situation financière des
collectivités territoriales puisque vous
savez que la journée complémentaire
d'inscription qui permet jusqu'au 31
janvier de rattacher des dépenses à
l'exercice précédent fait qu'il faut
qu'un jour quand même pour qu'on soit
absolument certain sur tous les
départements que le mouvement a pu avoir
lieu on a déjà quelques tendances et ses
tendances sont positives
avec une progression pour le coup
certaines de l’épargne des régions et
des départements mais là la taille et le
nombre fait que c'est assez facile de
consolider et de regarder où nous en
sommes
donc une progression d'épargne
malgré l'inflation qui a été connue mais
parce que l'inflation a aussi profité
aux recettes des régions grâce à la TVA
et on a gardé une dynamique de DMTO
élevée et une baisse des dépenses de RSA
de 5% sur la totalité de l'année 2022
qui explique pourquoi on s'est entre
guillemets retrouvés avec une
progression d'épargne sur ces sujets
pour les communes les tendances sont
bonnes même si elles ne sont pas
consolidées mais les premiers chiffres
dont on dispose font plutôt état d'un
recul de la dette et donc d'une là aussi
une capacité importante
vous m'avez interrogé très rapidement
sur quelques têtes de chapitres et je
laisserai volontiers les uns et les
autres venir je terminerai sur
l'ingénierie moi aussi puisque j'ai
promis d'être court et puis après
vraiment je reviendrai sur tous les
sujets sur lesquels vous décideriez de
m'interroger
le céréma
la dame la NCT puisque vous les avez
cités
qui sont des opérateurs qui ont été
créés il y a plus ou moins longtemps
pour certains il y a très peu de temps
pour d'autres il y a très longtemps
moi je ne crois pas je pense qu'il faut
toujours se méfier des idées qui en
apparence peuvent être bonnes mais qui
quand on les regarde
ensuite peuvent créer un certain nombre
d'effets de bord
le sujet c'est comme on les articules
comment on évite de créer des doublons
et comment ces structures ne se marchent
pas sur les pieds
mais
posé dans le même temps le constat qu'on
est face à des défis qui nécessitent des
moyens d'ingénierie importants
et arrive à la conclusion qu'on aurait
besoin de moins de structures pour le
faire me semble antinomique
ma conviction c'est qu'il faut des
structures qui soient suffisamment
souples pour pouvoir apporter un service
sur mesure et que si vous faites un gros
machin qui s'appelle demain le satellite
d'appui et d'ingénierie vous allez ou
perdre en agilité en souplesse ou ré
rigidifier là où au contraire depuis
quelques années le principe a été décidé
de regarder comment à destination des
élus locaux on crée une banque de
données ou de ressources et qui était
capable et susceptible d'aller faire du
sur-mesure
je crois à la souplesse je pense à
l'intérêt d'avoir des agences d'intérêt
général dans lesquels il n'y a pas des
gens qui sont des fonctionnaires et dans
lequel on peut profiter de statuts qui
sont plus souples qui sont moins rigides
et qui sont capables y compris de
pouvoir accompagner des idées qui
n'existent pas et qui n'ont pas vocation
à donner lieu à de la norme ou à la loi
mais à regarder comment des
expérimentations peuvent être conduites
comment on peut faire en sorte de les
généraliser et je me méfie de ce qui en
fusionnant des structures finit par
aboutir à des hausses de coups
dit autrement
de la même manière que je serai surpris
que vous puissiez ici en expliquant que
moins il y aura de communes moi il y
aura de dépenses je ne crois pas que
l'argument qui consisterait à dire que
moins il y a d'agences
moins il y aura de dépenses soit juste
la question
c'est la carte et la réalité dans
certains endroits il y a des fusions qui
peuvent avoir un intérêt surtout si
elles sont guidées par le sens de
l'intérêt général les la volonté
objective des uns et des autres dans
d'autres il peut s'agir de fausses
bonnes idées parce qu'une structure plus
petite et parfois plus attentive à ses
coûts et lutte parfois de manière plus
efficace contre le gaspillage de ses
ressources
voilà ce que je pouvais en avance de
phase madame la présidente de la
délégation vous dire avant de répondre
avec joie aux questions qui me seront
posées et en saluant effectivement la
présence à mes côtés à la fois de la
DGCL madame et du directeur général de
l'anct pour me contenter des directeurs
généraux même si je suis bien accompagné
par quelques autres collaborateurs de
mon cabinet ou des services pour être
capable de répondre à vos questions
merci Monsieur Mina merci pour la
sobriété de votre propos alors vous avez
toutefois tout en étant ensemble un peu
déformé mon propos monsieur le minis si
je peux me permettre avec respect je
dans mon propos sur l'ingénierie je n'ai
pas dit qu'il fallait moins j'ai dit
qu'il fallait mieux ce qui n'est pas du
tout la même chose et je pense que vous
voyez très bien vous mais très bien
compris et que effectivement on a eu
la le bonheur en quelque sorte d'en
parler avec les deux excellents
directeurs de la DGCL et de capacité et
que on sait que dans les territoires le
besoin d'ingénierie est différenciée
selon
la mobilisation sur ce thème des
intercos ou des départements mais qui
est un vrai sujet et mon collègue qui
est rouge qui est là pour en parler
c'est de la déconcentration du service
des concentrés de l'État dans les
territoires du circuit court et je
regarde ma collègue
Céline Brulin qui avait que Charles
Guénet ont commis aussi un excellent
rapport que nous avons remis hier à
Madame Faure et qui explique bien
les choses et que vous savez très bien
que notre esprit critique n'est même pas
taquin il est lucide et nous ne faisons
que faire
qu'exercer la fonction pour laquelle
nous avons été élu proposé et merci
Monsieur mise alors chers collègues nous
avons cinq prises de parole donc moi
j'ai mon mandataire je propose si vous
êtes d'accord de suivre la
recommandation du ministre naturellement
on ne peut pas ne pas parler du mais si
vous êtes d'accord compte tenu du
travail qui est engagé par la mission
spéciale celui qui a été fait par la
mission spéciale aujourd'hui par la
Commission et les débats que nous aurons
moi je propose comme ça tarde pas sur le
sujet parce que monsieur le ministre va
aussi
rencontrer la commission
mais si vous avez mis ça je personnel
sur le sujet à faire passer comme on dit
ouais donc je vais passer la parole
peut-être d'abord on peut faire un duo
si vous êtes d'accord monsieur ministre
de questions
donc notre collègue Michel Gréau mais
notre collègue Hervé gilet ensuite notre
collègue Eric est rouge qui a donc fait
cette excellent rapport sur les services
déconcentrés de l'État avec Agnès canae
et Sonia de la propreté qui s'intéresse
beaucoup aux questions outils de la
négation sur la revitalisation des
centres-villes voilà mes chers collègues
Michel merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre
depuis 2012 la DGF a baissé de plus de
14 milliards aujourd'hui les communes se
retrouvent en plus de l'inflation avec
un problème d'autonomie fiscale et
financière j'ai pu m'apercevoir que près
de 1/3 des communes sont
identifiés comme bénéficiaire dans le
cadre du filet de sécurité ces dernières
devront obligatoirement adopter des
budgets équilibrés contrairement à
l'état certains maires ont été dans
l'obligation d'abandonner leur projet
d'investissement comme adouchy-les-mines
dans le Nord et qui sait pourtant dans
le cas de la transition
ça répondait parfaitement comment
pouvons-nous accompagner au mieux les
communes dans la transition écologique
si celle-ci n'ont déjà pas les moyens
d'investir et qu'adviendra-t-il de ses
collectivités qui ont déjà perçu un
acompte pouvant atteindre 50% de la
dotation prévue pour leur futur budget
comment voyez-vous les choses merci
je vous remercie madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre bonjour vous avez
évoqué dans vos propos liminaires vous
interrogez par exemple quand on parlait
de
la conférence des Scott je voudrais vous
interroger sur la planification
territoriale et autres vision de la
planification territoriale nous l'avons
vu dans le cadre du projet de loi
accélération des énergies renouvelables
ce sujet est très particulier or il est
intéressant aujourd'hui d'essayer de
promouvoir un modèle sur notre
territoire national qui nous permettrait
d'être le plus cohérent possible or
aujourd'hui on a quand même des niveaux
assez différenciés en fonction à la fois
des régions et des départements pour le
coup les Scotts intégrateurs ont le
mérite de pouvoir associer d'abord
l'ensemble des communes adhérentes dans
une vision de projet territorial et des
schémas territoriaux de développement
des énergies renouvelables à l'échelle
des scottes ont une pertinence en termes
de projets territoire donc que les
Scotts soient intégrateurs et soit
effectivement logiquement
dans une logique ensuite de consommation
d'espace paraît effectivement tout à
fait naturel quel est votre vision à ce
titre justement de la promotion de ce
type de modèle du développement des
scottes ne croyez-vous pas qu'il y
aurait des articulations vraiment
pertinentes à renforcer entre les
différents niveaux régionaux
l'estradettes bien évidemment la
conférence des scottes les interscots de
telle manière à développer aussi et à
participer aux coopérations
territoriales sur les différents niveaux
Région Département métropole et
agglomération
très bien
d'abord pour répondre à la sénatrice
gréaume
le soutien aux collectivités il est très
exactement notamment au titre de la
transition ce qui explique la mise en
place du fond vert
on est pas ici dans l'hémicycle il y a
pas de journaliste on est entre nous
c'est juste le passage de 2 à 4
milliards des subventions
d'investissement collectivités
territoriales qui a été acté par le
budget le doublement
et ça
c'est pas de la recette de
fonctionnement ça a donc l'inconvénient
de pas compter dans l'épargne mais ça a
quand même le mérite de venir soutenir
une dynamique d'investissement dont on
sait que dans beaucoup de domaines elle
est absolument nécessaire
et je tiens à vous dire que le succès à
ce stade est au rendez-vous plus de 2500
dossiers déposés à date pour un
dispositif qui a officiellement ouvert
le 27 janvier qui n'a pas encore été
présenté à toutes les collectivités dans
tous les départements par les préfets ça
témoigne de quelque chose encore plus
intéressant les 13 portes d'entrée que
nous avions imaginé ont toutes trouvé à
ce stade preneuse on a des mers qui sont
venus pour l'érosion du trait de côte on
en a qui sont venus pour des projets de
replantation d'arbres on en a près de la
moitié qui sont sur la rénovation
thermique ou la rénovation de
l'éclairage public à ce stade mais sa
témoigne vraiment un de l'utilité du
dispositif et de du fait qu'on a bien
fait d'imaginer un dispositif large
ensuite sur la DGF proprement dit
c'est la première année depuis 13 ans où
elle progresse certes seulement de 320
millions d'euros mais vous avez rappelé
ce qui avait été l'ampleur des baisses
en particulier pendant le quinquennat
2012-2017 où on a atteint des niveaux de
diminution de la DGF qui
qu'on mesure encore aujourd'hui quand on
compare les situations
mais je le redis à la minute où nous
nous parlons et sous réserve de la photo
très nette que nous aurons le 15 février
nous n'avons pas à ce stade
quand on agglomère le bloc communal une
photographie qui montre que les finances
se sont dégradées en 2022
je pense que la vérité est un peu plus
nuancée et qu'on découvrira quand on
regardea dans le détail qu'on a plus un
sujet de communes centre que de commune
dit autrement un bouclier tarifaire
intégral sur toutes les communes ayant
moins de 10 employés et moins de 2
millions d'euros de budget à
certainement préserver les plus petites
dans lesquelles le montant moyen des
dépenses est en moins élevé et la
proportion d'investis d'investissement
étant plus faible l'inflation a sans
doute moins impacté les budgets en
revanche dans les communes centres
disposant de bâtiments qui nécessitent
en termes de chauffage et d'électricité
des charges de centralité qui se
reflètent pour une partie plus grande et
je parle pas des métropoles je parle des
chefs lieux de canton je parle de de
toutes les communes qui jouent un peu un
rôle de centralité il est vraisemblable
qu'on n'aura pas exactement la même
photo
si cette bonne situation se confirme
nous pourrions avoir un petit sujet sur
le filet
pour répondre à la deuxième partie de
votre question moi l'idée
on construit un dispositif à Doc
qui va permettre de cibler l'effort
sur ceux qui en ont besoin plutôt que de
créer un effet d'aubaine si certains
n'ont pas de baisse de leur épargne mais
qui se retrouvent avec une progression
ça ne me choque pas intellectuellement
ça va dans le sens de beaucoup de
mécanismes d'ailleurs de solidarité que
nous appliquons dans notre domaine on
note pas la même chose à tout le monde
on tient compte de la situation réelle
du niveau de revenu et on tient compte
de la réalité de la situation
à la minute où nous nous parlons quand
je regarde le filet que vous avez voté
au moment de la loi de finances
rectificative
4100 communes on ont demandé
l'activation
générant environ 100 millions d'euros
d'acompte
ce qui veut dire que sur cette base il
n'est pas certain
que nous attendrions les 430 millions
d'euros que vous avez voté
et c'est dans une hypothèse où aucune
des 4100 ne se retrouverait à devoir
rendre l'argent parce qu'il y a eu en
plus une erreur d'appréciation
donc il n'est pas certain
malgré le vote qui a eu lieu qu'on est
assez de collectivités que ce soit saisi
du dispositif on va pas tarder à savoir
et on regardera puisque les comptes
administratifs serviront de juge de paix
ce que j'aimerais
c'est qu'on puisse assez vite avoir des
projections du filet de sécurité qu'on a
voté dans le cadre du PLF 2023 parce que
là c'est pas 400 millions c'est un
milliard et demi et la somme elle a pas
été déterminée par hasard elle a été
faite pour tenir compte de l'ampleur de
l'évolution énergétique moi je considère
que cette aide aux collectivités d'un
milliard et demi elle nous engage et
donc s'il y a des critères à bouger il
est sans doute souhaitable qu'on le
fasse avant qui est la tentation d'aller
constater que tout n'a pas été dépensé
que ça retombe dans le pot commun
et donc je pense que c'est là dessus
quand on aura les chiffres définitifs au
15 février qui sera utile qu'on regarde
les projections que nous avons vous avez
abaissé et élargi la porte en faisant en
sorte que la perte d'épargne ne soit
plus de 22,5%. donc ça ça va dans le bon
sens
si j'ai une progression globale de
l'épargne à l'échelle du bloc ça veut
sans doute dire que c'est peut-être pas
là où il faut fléchir le l'effort voilà
je peux pas aller beaucoup plus loin ce
matin parce qu'il me manque ces éléments
je peux vous donner ces chiffres sur le
filet c'est ce que je viens de faire les
4100 les 100 millions et dès qu'on aura
des résultats plus précis évidemment
vous les communiquera
je veux dire au sénateur gilet que je
crois au Scott je crois la nécessité
d'avoir une vision de planification
je pense qu'on a un souci dans ce pays
en matière de droit de l'urbanisme
qui est l'absence d'interscotte et de la
capacité à ce que deux territoires
vérifient que leur projections vont dans
le bon sens je pense que si on s'amusait
à faire les projections de progression
de population de tous les scottes de
France et de progression d'emploi on
s'apercevrait que tout le monde se voit
plus beau qu'il naît à la fin et que
tout le monde a tendance à surestimer ce
que sera son développement ses besoins
en termes de fonciers en termes de
logements et en termes de nombre
d'hectares
et ça plaide si je peux me permettre
pour avoir des instances dans lesquelles
on est capable de se parler la limite
c'est faut-il rajouter des choses
au-delà du stradet et des scottes et de
la capacité de se parler est-ce qu'on
doit rajouter des couches quand vous
êtes mère que vous retrouvez déjà à
devoir demander à l'intercommunalité
parce que vous avez un pluie une
modification sur une parcelle sur
laquelle vous avez des attentes on va
vérifier que ces conformes au Scott qui
a été voté si demain il faut se
rapprocher de la Fédération nationale
des scottes ou de l'Inter Scott ou du
stradead pour obtenir une modif on va
désespérer une partie de nos élus donc
ce que je crois sans contexte très lourd
que ça coûte très cher
la somme qu'il faut dépenser pour être
capable de monter un Scott quand on la
rapporte elle est particulièrement
élevée mon souci de pas alourdir les
dépenses des collectivités locales et de
pas complexifier un truc qui éloigne les
mères notamment les plus petits d'un
dispositif qui devient tellement
technique qui sont largués qui sont dans
la main des experts et que je pense
qu'il faut bouger ça avec prudence
je pense qu'il faut des pluies
et je pense qu'il faut des pluies
dans la plupart du territoire parce que
c'est le bon niveau d'intégration qui
permet de discuter de la manière dont
les choses se passent
je pense que la contrepartie d'une
garantie rurale dans le zan pourrait
être de réduire le RNU et les secteurs
dans lesquels il n'y a pas
de plan d'urbanisme donnant les choses à
voir
je pense que le Scott doit rester le
pivot d'une vision à l'échelle d'un
bassin de territoire et que plutôt que
de créer une échelle intermédiaire c'est
plutôt dans le stradette qu'il faut
avoir une forme d'instance de dialogue
et discussion plutôt de se rajouter
autre chose vous m'avez demandé ce que
je pensais je vous réponds je ne
prétends absolument pas sur ces sujets
avoir une opinion
mais en tout cas voilà ce que je pense
merci Monsieur peut-être avant de passer
la parole donc à notre collègue à nos
Gilles Sonia de la pauvreté peut-être en
écho à ce que vous disiez effectivement
nous vous remercions de pouvoir quand
cela sera possible communiquer
la situation financière moi j'entends ce
que l'on dit je m'en réjouis si la
situation
financière et et bonne OK et en même
temps je me dis que les élus locaux qui
ont l'obligation d'avoir des budgets
équilibrés et qui se mettent à l'abri
des intempéries à venir ont aussi sans
aucun doute en 2022 est extrêmement
précautionneux et jouer les fourmis
plutôt que les cigales et décaler des
choses et que vous avez tout à fait
raison de dire qu'il y a une diversité
de situations et que moi comme vous je
n'ose ni je n'ose pas les communes
rurales aux communes urbaines mais il y
a une vraie fonction de centra ou des
communes sont en budget de
fonctionnement
amener à assumer des services ceux qui
sont liés à leur fonction parce qu'elles
ont un collège parce qu'elles ont un
certain nombre de fonctions de
centralité et ça il faut il faut qu'on y
va et dernier point sur le filet de
sécurité alors monsieur le ministre nous
le filet de sécurité on a dit
pardonnez-moi que celui qu'on a évoqué
en 2022 c'est un peu comme quand je
passe devant ma banque qui fait un
affichage en venez on va vous prêter de
l'argent voilà donc je rentre à la
banque le banquier est très accueillant
et puis il me dit très très bien votre
situation nous intéresse alors il dit à
la fin ah oui alors dommage il y a une
condition que vous ne remplissez pas
parce que vous savez comme moi que vous
avez pris le taux d'épargne brut et
qu'ensuite à l'intérieur il devait y
avoir une composition et que
l'objectif qui avait été fixé je doute
pas de la bonne volonté des choses
garantissait déjà le qu'on ne
dépenserait pas tout et que il y aura
moins de communes de toucher donc
heureusement en 2023 les choses ont été
un peu
revu donc attendons et voir et dernière
remarque sur la question de notre
collègue moi je pense qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui il faut qu'on soit en
cohérence sur le on va dire le
développement de nos communes chacun a
compris que la commune elle peut plus
faire les choses seul sans en parler à
son voisin et que l'interscope est aussi
important toutefois monsieur le ministre
moi je ne suis pas une adepte forcée ou
un missionnaire du du peluy parce que je
pense que le peluy n'est pas forcément
la règle que les communes doivent
travailler ensemble mais sans avoir un
outil elles peuvent aussi faire un plage
et que comme ici nous défendons la
responsabilité et la liberté locale moi
je pense que s'il faut encourager les
élus et les accompagner pour réfléchir à
la bonne échelle ça n'est pas en mettant
un nouvel instrument
illustrative le peluy quand réglera les
choses merci Monsieur alors
Eric guerrou chez Sonia de la pauvreté
merci madame la Présidente bonjour
monsieur le ministre quelques réflexions
aussi sur ce que sur la réponse que vous
avez apporté tout à l'heure sur sur
l'agence signification c'est pas un
problème de coup on parlait pas en terme
de coûts on parlait en termes de
fonctionnalités c'est pas exactement la
même chose et on l'espèce le vrai
problème de l'agenceification c'est la
question de l'articulation avec les
services déconcentrés de l'État d'une
part et d'autre part la construction
d'une doctrine à l'intérieur des agences
qui peut s'appliquer de manière trop
uniforme il y a de nombreux travaux de
recherche qui ont porté sur ce point
donc la densification porte en soi
également une limite en tant que modèle
deuxième point mais très rapidement
parce qu'effectivement on y reviendra
celui du zan j'aurais tendance à vous
dire comme dans les cours d'école c'est
celui qui dit qui est parce que vous
nous parlez de la difficulté du filet de
de sécurité enfin exactement
du petit
la petite garantie qu'on apporterait à
l'ensemble des des communes rurales mais
cette difficulté vient de la difficulté
initiale du texte qui traite de la même
façon des situations qui sont
profondément inégales et comme
dans ce texte comme dans d'autres parce
que on a une loi 3DS mais excusez-moi
mais c'est de la partie sur la
différenciation elle est inexistante
donc dans la mesure on peut pas faire de
différenciation dans un cadre
territorial il faut bien trouver des
solutions pour notamment dans le monde
rural garantir une possibilité
ultérieure après on peut revenir sur la
question de la question de la question
du dosage mais tant que cette loi sur le
zan ne rentrera pas dans des logiques de
différenciation et traitera de la même
façon des situations qui sont éminemment
différentes avec des territoires en
emprise des territoires en méprises on
aura des difficultés qui seront
cumulatives dans le point dernier point
et cette fois-ci de manière très précise
le décret sur les zones tendues
a été reporté et son application d'après
ce que nous a dit Monsieur Attal
se fera en 2024 alors moi j'entends les
effets de bord entre la TLV et la THLV
j'entends les difficultés d'articulation
je voudrais juste vous dire et
assez tranquillement que je ne pense pas
que le gouvernement prenne la mesure de
l'urgence dans les territoires qui sont
sous tension notamment les territoires
littoraux
nous sommes en train de manière
cumulative d'arriver à une éviction de
population qui génère une frustration
folle et a juste titre tout simplement
parce que des gens ne sont plus capables
de se loger chez eux et que très
paradoxalement ce sont souvent les gens
qui par ailleurs reviennent dans la zone
où ils habitaient pour assurer le
service ou le travail nécessaire au
nouveau résident cette situation elle
est complètement intenable il y a eu
hier une
qagée sur la question des plateformes
juste deux chiffres dans mon département
le département des Landes la plateforme
Airbnb a connu de manière incroyable une
progression de 125% sur un an et ça
rapporte 15 millions localement aux
propriétaires concernés
et donc bien entendu ça génère une
attente une attente forte ça génère
aussi une attente sur les résidences de
de tourisme ça génère des difficultés
qui sont majeures et qui je le dis très
tranquillement vont mener à des
problèmes sociaux d'une ampleur folle et
vous savez bien que la litorisation est
importante en France et que dans l'état
actuel des choses nous dispensons pas
d'assez d'outils repousser j'entends les
effets de bord mais repoussez cette ce
début de solution qui n'est qu'un début
de solution et bien en 2024 ça sera
encore plus difficile merci
la parole à notre collègue Sonia de la
pauvreté du littoral aussi ce qui est du
Calvados et je remercie Corinne Ferret
qui vient d'annuler sa demande de prise
de parole parce que sa question est
celle qui est portée par Eric et comme
nous sommes nombreux à parler merci
correct Sonia oui merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre donc je
vais faire une incise courte mais comme
elle a été comme ça a été évoquée sur le
zan vous l'avez bien compris ça sera
court mais juste pour réagir à vos
propos vous évoquer la question des
usines à gaz moi je dis chiche c'est à
dire que c'est utilisé une expression un
peu caricaturale un brin caricatural
pour pour traiter de la question de ce
que nous souhaitons organiser pour que
les élus locaux et voix au chapitre sur
les décisions qui les concernent et
surtout qui concerne les habitants de
leur commune c'est essentiel et donc en
fait ce qui est proposé dans la
proposition de loi c'est comment on fait
pour que les cellules locaux
puissent donner leur avis mais pas que
puissent décider de ce qui va être versé
au pot national dans les projets ce qui
va être versé au cours des régionales et
des arbitrages divers et variés et que
un certain nombre de décisions soient
pas prises de la part de l'État et
descendent dans les territoires sans
qu'on soit au courant ne serait-ce que
les questions de calendrier d'ajustement
de calendrier de critères et de taille
des enveloppes sont des questions sur
lesquelles ils peuvent quand même avoir
leur mot à dire
sans pour autant renier l'intérêt du zan
en ce qui concerne l'ingénierie je
voulais juste vous poser une question
vous avez à juste titre et évoquer
l'ingénierie de l'État il y a
l'ingénierie locale aussi et donc je
voulais vous interroger sur sur le rôle
que vous souhaitez voir jouer par
l'ingénierie locale donc je parle des
agents d'urbanisme mais il y a aussi des
ingénieries départementales il y a des
il y a plusieurs types d'ingénierie il y
a aussi les EPL qui interviennent dans
la maîtrise du foncier par exemple ou
dans la maîtrise d'ouvrage donc tout ça
c'est ce qui fait j'allais dire
l'agilité du terrain et c'est tous les
outils que les élus avec astuces ont
trouvé et que
comment dire la loi et l'État leur ont
laissé comme étant possible mais du bout
des doigts quand même parce qu'on voit
que les contrôles de plus en plus
nombreux sont en train de contraindre de
plus en plus de façon de plus en plus
étroite cette ingénierie locale ces
outils là ils en ont besoin sur le
terrain et même si la NCT a été créée il
est nécessaire de les conforter parce
qu'ils sont à la main des élus locaux
entre guillemets c'est à dire que c'est
des élus locaux sont présents dedans et
donc c'est vraiment de l'ingénierie de
territoires
et donc voilà avoir votre point de vue
sur la façon dont les choses peuvent
s'articuler ma dernière question porte
sur la question la maîtrise du foncier
dont on voit que quand on nous avons un
produit un rapport à la dans la des
questions collectivité
territoriale et des entreprises avec mes
collègues Cointreau
babaris et de villa sur action cœur de
ville et petite ville de main et là qui
sont des grandes et petites et moyennes
centralité
urbaines et la maîtrise du foncier si on
traite de la question d'usage aussi
c'est le cœur du réacteur des politiques
publiques on voit bien que le devenir
des friches est essentiel mais pour ça
il faut maîtriser le foncier et dans les
friches il y a pas il y a pas que des
friches j'allais dire de mauvaise
qualité entre guillemets en termes de
pollution ou de revalorisation il y a
tous les pas de porte dans toutes les
communes on voit qu'il y a une espèce de
spéculation foncière anticipatrice
assez excessive dans les territoires de
maîtrise des pas de ports des locaux
d'habitation y compris dans les petites
communes et donc
ma question porte sur quels outils vous
souhaitez
[Musique]
de mettre en place améliorer ou en tout
cas de quelle façon souhaitent
comptez-vous soutenir les les
collectivités pour qu'elles aient la
main sur la maîtrise du foncier pour
éviter cette impossibilité à mettre en
oeuvre d'usane or initiative privée et à
des coûts qui feront que demain on ne
pourra vivre que dans des logements
très chers donc de grandes difficultés
finalement à mettre en place les
politiques publiques et puis
ma dernière question va apporter sur le
le fond vert je suis désolé hein c'est
un peu il y a plusieurs questions
le fond vert on a une vraie question
c'est comment comment vont être décidés
les enveloppes qui vont atterrir dans
les départements c'est une question à la
fois de la part de l'État et des
services de l'État mais à la fois de la
part des locaux bien évidemment
parce que
il est il est vendu en vrai il est
qualifié comme étant
très libre d'usage en réalité on a quand
même besoin de savoir de façon dont les
enveloppe seront réparties puisque la
liberté est quand même cadrée par un
certain nombre d'objectifs
et au bout du compte il y a une
interrogation sur la façon dont les
choses vont être comment dire vraiment
différencier et vraiment à la main du
territoire je vous remercie merci plus
chers collègues alors juste un mot je
pense que la question
une partie de la question de Sonia de la
porte sur une question essentielle qui
est je crois monsieur le ministre me
semble-t-il qui relève sans doute
d'abord de votre initiative c'est
comment on finance tout ça veut pas dire
non réfléchit pas et juste un point sur
la question d'Eric et rouges pour être
comme beaucoup d'entre nous ici du
littoral d'un département littoral et en
Bretagne
sa question est
fin du mois l'affirmation qu'il y a
nécessité à ne pas reculer est
extrêmement importante parce qu'on a une
question de logement des gens qui
travaillent pour ceux qui peuvent
aujourd'hui s'offrir une résidence et on
a aussi une question pour l'économie
locale avec comment loge les saisonniers
donc vraiment je pense qu'on a là une
urgence
sociale et économique merci Monsieur le
Ministre ensuite pardon
Bernard notre
lui Bernard delcro et une variante avec
Jean-Marie maison variante pour le
prénom bien sûr
bon d'abord sur les deux sur les deux
questions qui viennent de mettre posées
plusieurs sujets qui touchent d'abord
autour d'usage etc
si mes propos ont été mal compris je les
précise
je ne dis absolument pas que la PPL est
une usine à gaz parce qu'à certains
égards le zan en lui-même dans sa
conception dans le fait que tout à coup
on compte on fait des trajectoires on
divise s'inscrit dans une logique
complexe ce que je dis c'est que au
moment où on va retoucher
législativement le dispositif
demandons-nous non pas comme on le
complexifie c'était ça le sens de mes
propos mais comment on mais comment on
le facilite et on transforme je suis
dans une position un peu paradoxale qui
est de défendre un texte que je n'ai pas
voté puisque je n'étais pas
parlementaire et dont j'ai eu à me
confronter aux difficultés d'application
en réalisant mon propre Scott et je me
retrouve maintenant comme ministre à
défendre le principe de ce qui a été
voté par une large majorité même si il y
a eu quelques exceptions à voter cette
loi climat est résilience mais qui a été
voté à une très large majorité et de
l'Assemblée et du Sénat de façon très
transpartisane
qui doit au moins nous conduire à une
chose c'est que sans doute qu'une loi
avec 35 articles n'est pas le meilleur
moyen de faire en sorte que chacun
d'entre eux soit étudié de manière
approfondie
et dans ce texte il y avait les idées
feuilles il y avait deux trois autres
trucs sur lequel on se rend compte là
aussi qu'on a des intentions qui sont
bonnes et qu'on a parfois dans les
modalités de trois petits sujets qui
sont à revoir je me permets quand même
pour que les choses soient totalement
claires de rappeler que le zan faisait
partie des propositions très fortes de
la convention citoyenne que il arrive
parfois dans d'autres enceintes que
certains qui reprochent au gouvernement
de ne pas avoir suffisamment tenu compte
de ce qui s'était dit n'ont aucun
problème pour taper sur une mesure qui
dans le même temps
s'inscrit pourtant à la croisée de
plusieurs chemins de vertus
ne partificialiser
c'est rendre possible la recharge des
nappes phréatiques c'est préserver des
îlots de fraîcheur naturel c'est nous
donner les moyens de faire en sorte de
pouvoir conserver une souveraineté
agricole et alimentaire ou la retrouver
donc c'est un objectif sur lequel nous
devrions d'autant plus nous retrouver
qu'il n'y a pas de corrélation entre
l'imperméabilisation qui a été conduite
ces dernières années l'évolution de la
population
et je le dis pour les élus du littoral
et d'ailleurs il n'y a pas non plus de
corrélation entre les gains de
population et les pourcentages
d'artificialisation il y a des secteurs
dans lesquels on a accueilli beaucoup de
populations avec peu d'hectares il y a
des endroits dans lesquels on a perdu de
la population et on s'est étendu bon que
dit la loi et là c'est pas la discussion
qu'on est en train d'avoir
je me permets quand même y compris par
rapport à ce que disait Sonia de la
prévôté sur l'association des élus
qu'est-ce que vous avez voté vous
Parlement
le fait qu'on allait pas appliquer ce
truc de manière aveugle et qu'on allait
faire confiance aux élus locaux
c'est ça ce qui est voté en disant on va
faire confiance aux régions parce qu'on
peut pas descendre sur les trajectoires
c'est ce que le Parlement a décidé un
niveau trop bas qui fait qu'à ce
moment-là on ne pourrait pas tenir
compte des dynamiques de population dans
l'esprit c'est pour répartir la charge
de manière intelligente il faut que je
sois une échelle qui soit suffisamment
vaste pour répartir le foncier et je
fais confiance aux régions pour ensuite
à l'intérieur de leur territoire donner
davantage à ceux qui vont avoir plus de
besoins tenir compte des efforts passés
etc bon
on est face à une situation paradoxale
il y a des collectivités qui disent
aucun problème je suis tout à fait prêt
assumer ce rôle il y a des régions qui
disent moi c'est trop compliqué je ferai
50% pour tout le monde ce qui serait la
négation même d'une forme de justice
et là ça ne me choquerait pas qu'on dise
la région qui refuse de délibérer on
redonne le pouvoir à l'état
mais comment dans la chambre des
collectivités territoriales avec les
convictions qui sont les miennes
d'anciens présidents de départements et
président de d'intercaux je peux vouloir
que ce soit à la préfecture que se
décide les trajectoires foncières entre
collectivités
et en tant qu'en science sénateur donc
le fond de ma pensée c'est qu'il faut
préserver un dispositif de partage entre
les uns et les autres si la conférence
des scottes était le moyen de faire en
sorte que tous les maires du territoire
étaient entendus pardonnez-moi de vous
le dire mais ça saurait vous savez très
bien que dans une conférence des scottes
qui s'exprime les présidents des scottes
et un nombre d'élus qui sont eux-mêmes
une émanation de l'étage du dessous mais
tout le monde n'a pas voix au chapitre
il y a une forme de démocratie
représentative donc dire qu'au motif
qu'on institutionnaliserait une
conférence des scottes qui permettrait
de discuter puisque c'est un des
articles ça permettrait d'associer les
élus locaux
ça ne me semble pas être un argument
d'iriment et de la même manière que vous
représentez des territoires
et que vous parlez pour le nom des élus
qui vous ont choisi
imaginez qu'on passe à la démocratie
directe dans lequel au lieu d'avoir des
sénateurs on demanderait à tous les
maires sur tous les sujets de s'exprimer
ne serait pas non plus une garantie
d'une meilleure prise en compte parce
que on sait qu'il y a dans tout
assemblée quelle qu'elle soit des gens
qui à ce moment-là prendront la parole
de façon plus forte ou plus importante
que d'autres
donc oui pour trouver un mécanisme non
pour faire croire à l'illusion que on se
retrouvera dans une situation on pourra
entendre tout le monde y compris et
j'assume pleinement ses propos
parce que tout le monde est d'accord
pour l'artificialisation sur le principe
mais personne quand il regarde son
propre territoire
très peu sont capables d'objectivité
parce que la peur de manquer conduit en
vouloir davantage que ce dont on a
besoin et je vous le dis c'est très
simple prenez les scottes regardez les
scottes dans lesquels et même les plus
ou les pH dans lesquels on atteint les
objectifs et où à la fin de la période
donnée les espaces qui étaient prévus
pour assurer l'artificialisation ont été
faits
c'est même pas un tiers du territoire
national il y a des endroits où c'est le
cas plutôt dans l'Ouest compte tenu des
progressions de population
mais à l'échelle nationale vous avez des
quantités d'endroits on vous fait des
projections qui ne sont pas atteintes
donc on a des marges on a des sujets sur
lesquels on peut travailler de manière
extrêmement
concrète le littoral de manière plus
large et les plateformes
je crois la décentralisation
je pense que si je fige des règles à
l'échelle nationale avec des situations
qui n'ont rien à voir je vais au devant
de difficultés et je pense même que sur
la question des Herbiers des plateformes
on peut pas comparer celui qui loue
pendant quelques jours sa résidence
principale parce qu'il la quitte de
celui qui achète volontairement un
appartement voire un immeuble pour en
faire de la location courte durée plutôt
que pour faire de la location donc durée
et saisonnière
et donc il faut pas qu'on ait une loi
qui entre guillemets bouleverse ce que
peuvent être des compléments de revenus
pour des propriétaires qui n'ont qu'un
bien et qui vont faire en sorte de
financer une partie de leurs vacances en
étant plus chez eux et en le louant à
quelqu'un d'autre avec ceux qui
détourneraient l'objet entre guillemets
des plateformes de ce qui a été décidé
pour devenir des loueurs professionnels
qui se contentent de faire de la
location de courte durée
nous avons aujourd'hui la loi en Europe
par rapport à ces plateformes qui est la
plus poussée celle qui donne le plus
d'instruments à la main des élus et on a
des mers de droite et de gauche
qui se saisissent parfois de ces
instruments avec beaucoup d'efficacité
pour avoir regardé le truc dans le
détail quand vous pensez qu'à La Baule
le maire Franck Louvrier interdit
d'avoir plus de un logement Airbnb
pour un propriétaire et que au-delà il
faut compenser avec de la longue durée
quand vous regardez ce qui se passe à
Biarritz quand vous regardez ce qui se
passe à la recherche il y a des trous
dans la raquette qu'il faut être capable
de compléter la proposition que je fais
et qui est très simple elle est pour moi
directement reliée à la Réunion que
j'aurais mardi matin avec toutes les
associations d'élus sur la
décentralisation du logement
les outils les plus puissants sont liés
à votre statut de zone tendue on a deux
options on décorait ou on fait sauter la
condition de zone tendue
où on décentralise la détermination de
ce qui est une zone tendue
et j'avoue que la deuxième hypothèse
autour du Pinel breton me semble être
prometteuse
mais j'ai pas d'obstacles à ce que
demain dans les discussions qu'on aura
avec les élus on puisse aussi considérer
qu'il y a peut-être des règles qui
convient de modifier y compris sur ces
questions de plateformes ce que je
souhaite c'est que le dialogue se fasse
avec l'AMF avec la MRF avec la DF avec
les associations d'élus pour qu'on
trouve le bon dispositif
et qu'on entendent le retour
d'expérience de ce qui pour cette
confronté aux limites du texte vont être
capables de nous expliquer comment aller
plus loin
voilà ce que je peux rapidement dire
parce que je pense que ce sujet là il
commence mardi mais il a vocation
ensuite évidemment à trouver son doute
une ville législative c'est le sujet qui
est sur le dessus de la pile en terme de
décentralisation et en termes
d'évolution de compétences je précise
que dans mon esprit c'est ce que je
dirais mardi aux associations d'élus je
suis prêt à aller très loin
à l'exception des aPL qui ne sont pas
sur la table parce qu'elle relève de la
solidarité nationale et qui peut pas y
avoir de décentralisation des aPL et de
la question de l'hébergement d'urgence
qui est complexe parce qu'elle est aussi
liée à la maîtrise des flux migratoires
et que dire aux élus vous vous
débrouillez sur les questions
d'hébergement alors qu'ils n'ont pas
complètement la main sur ce que peuvent
être les flux tout le reste discute
y compris le soutien en mer bâtisseurs
parce que j'aimerais mes chers collègues
vous dire qu'on est quand même en train
d'avoir une drôle de discussion sur le
fait qu'on pourrait manquer de terrain
pour construire alors qu'aujourd'hui une
des difficultés qu'on rencontre dans
beaucoup d'endroits c'est des mères qui
refusent de signer des permis de
construire compte tenu de la réaction
des voisins et un recul des mises en
chantier
qui s'explique par quelques raisons
conjoncturelles augmentation du prix des
matériaux relèvement de des taux
d'emprunt mais je peux vous assurer que
les promoteurs immobiliers et plus
largement un certain nombre de d'acteurs
expliquent la difficulté qu'ils ont à
trouver des mères qui sont enclins
accueillir des nouveaux projets sur leur
territoire
et ça me frappe parce que c'est vraiment
au cours des deux derniers mois ce que
j'ai beaucoup entendu
sur les agences
je crois profondément aux agences
locales et je pense qu'elle participe de
la libre administration de ce pays
et que il faut pas légiférer sur quelque
chose qui reflète la diversité du pays
dans certains endroits c'est des agences
d'urbanisme et c'est super dans d'autres
c'est une SPL qui a une un sujet
particulier dans un troisième c'est une
ATD
d'ingénierie dans une quatrième c'est la
région qui a monté une agence de la
transition écologique je pense au grand
test parce que c'est ce qu'ils ont fait
dans un autre
laissons la liberté locale se mettre en
place on a des diversités de situations
qui militent pour connait une diversité
et c'est quoi la NCT
c'est le grand frère national c'est la
déclinaison nationale
de ces agences locales
avec un principe de subsidiarité on n'a
pas vocation à faire sur le plan
national ce qui se passerait mais le
territoire qui n'a rien parce que
l'intercommunalité est trop petite parce
que le département a fermé son agence
parce qu'il l'a jamais ouvertes qu'on
lui permette d'avoir une sorte de filet
de sécurité nationale en termes
d'ingénierie ou que pour défricher des
sujets
comme avec cœur de ville on s'appuie sur
un dispositif national de recueil des
bonnes pratiques et qui permet de d'être
un couteau suisse ça me semble
souhaitable mais pour le reste je suis
extrêmement favorable à cette forme et
je vais plus loin c'est pareil pour le
foncier
dans certains endroits
et j'en connais bien
c'est pas sur un établissement public
foncier
que porte l'acquisition potentielle de
c'est sur une scène
c'est sur une SPL sans lever de taxe
avec parfois des logiques d'achat de
patrimoine suffisamment en avance en
plus pour limiter les coûts de ce qui
aura à construire
là-dessus je pense que le Sénat fait
œuvre très utile avec la PPL zan sur les
outils de sursis à statuer et de
préemption
parce que le zan crée par définition une
tout à coup une tension sur les prix
avec une raréfaction anticipée de ce que
seront les terrains disponibles donc on
est des mécanismes antispéculatifs c'est
souhaitable et je vais plus loin
j'aimerais qu'on ait une taxation
significative de l'artificialisation
on ne peut pas expliquer qu'on doit
lutter contre l'artificialisation et ne
pas faire en sorte qu'il y a un signal
prix on a un terrain agricole qui
devient constructible il faut qu'une
part substantielle de la plus-value qui
est générée par la loi puisque la loi
dit un jour ça va s'arrêter donc vous
créez un effet de rareté qui génère
à ce moment là un surprofit
il faut taxer cette rente de manière à
alimenter les caisses des collectivités
locales et des communes pour leur
permettre de conduire une stratégie de
sobriété foncière par ailleurs et là il
y aurait une logique qui pourrait être
vertueuse ça ne figure pas dans la
proposition ça me semble faire partie
des choses qui pourraient utilement être
mis en avant
voilà pour aller très vite sur les
différents sujets agences
fonciers
et zan ce que je peux être amené à vous
dire je termine juste par un truc
on a des milliers de communes qui sont
déjà aux héros artificialisation net
sans le savoir
des milliers
celles qui se retrouvent en zone
inondable
celles qui se retrouvent en étant cerné
par des Appellations d'Origine Contrôlée
celles qui ont épuisé le foncier qui est
des disponible sur leur territoire et
qui se reconstruisent sur elle-même je
pense à Paris mais il y a plein
d'exemples dans nos communes puisque il
y a pas de taille moyenne vous avez
parfois des communes qui sont toutes
petites d'autres qui sont immenses avec
des variations qui sont assez
considérables en fonction des
territoires
et donc
cette réalité là il faut aussi qu'on la
prenne en compte parce qu'il nous arrive
parfois de voir des difficultés là où
elles ne sont pas
et je pense que le principal défaut
d'usane à la fin c'est son titre qui
donne le sentiment que c'est zéro tout
de suite alors que ça correspond pas à
la réalité et j'aimerais juste qu'on se
redonne un chiffre
12500 hectares
c'est la moyenne de ce qu'on va avoir le
droit d'artificaliser pour les 10 ans
qui arrivent
et il y a 200 000 hectares de friches en
bonus
entre guillemets dans ce pays 200 000
hectares et c'est friche ce sont des
friches d'une certaine taille je ne
compte pas
là d'encreuse à l'intérieur de la ville
la maison vide à tel ou tel endroit la
serre abandonnée avec une plateforme
bétonée qui pourrait faire l'objet d'une
renaturation donc on a vraiment des
enjeux et des marges sur lesquelles il
convient qu'on se concentre
fond vert
les enveloppes ont été
répartis par préfète département qui
dispose donc de sommes qui leur
permettent aujourd'hui d'engager le
dialogue vis-à-vis des élus locaux et ce
dialogue à ma connaissance a commencé
presque partout
avec ensuite des modes de fonctionnement
différents dans certains endroits les
préférences souhaité associer les élus
pour savoir s'il y avait des consignes
sur la façon d'aller réserver des
crédits dans d'autres ils attendent des
remontées de dossiers pour ensuite
éventuellement provoquer des réunions de
ce type et pour savoir s'il y aura
matière arbitrage donc on a aujourd'hui
une diversité de situations moi j'ai
fixé deux consignes pas d'appel à
projets et d'appel à manifestation
d'intérêt des réponses qui soient
extrêmement rapides parce que le fond je
l'ai obtenu pour l'année 2023 mais dans
ma tête la manière dont on va l'exécuter
cette année nous permettra d'avoir des
arguments pour en demander la
prolongation en termes de soutien aux
collectivités territoriales et sans
doute pour mieux fléchir sur là où sont
les besoins en termes de transition
écologique
nous suivrons avec intérêt cette
réflexion sur la décentralisation au
niveau du logement dont vous parlez et
je suis très heureuse que
l'expérimentation bretonne sur le Pinel
breton qui était pour nous une
inspiration remarquable et qui a été
obtenue à l'époque où Édouard philippe
était premier ministre et où il y avait
un revirement sur Notre Dame des Landes
puisse aujourd'hui
apparaître extrêmement vertueux alors
mes chers collègues je passe la parole
donc à Bernard buis Bernard delcro
Jean-Marie maison si vous pouvez être
aussi sobre que le zan
mais avec intelligence là voilà vous le
saurez merci
Bernard oui merci je serai très rapide
puisque ce ministre viendrait pendant la
question sur le fond vert puisque
c'était la question que j'ai envisagé de
poser et effectivement je voulais
vraiment confirmer que c'était une
attente forte dans les territoires et je
vois que de nombreuses communes dans la
Drôme ont déjà déposé des dossiers donc
leur attente est forte maintenant ce
qu'ils veulent savoir c'est dans combien
délais ils auront une réponse parce
qu'avec l'inflation les dossiers
aujourd'hui augmentent très vite et ou
plutôt ils ont la réponse au plus tôt
ils peuvent commencer les travaux
si pour sobriété remarquable Bernard
delcro merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le ministre de cet échange très
intéressant ce matin je voudrais sans
être long madame la Présidente je vous
le promets
évoqué quand même rebondir rapidement
sur votre point introductif sur le zan
évoquer la finance des collectivités et
les compétences sur Lausanne vous avez
dit Monsieur le Ministre donner la même
chose à tout le monde ça n'est pas la
justice
il ne s'agit pas de donner la même chose
à tout le monde avec le hectare il
s'agit d'assurer une garantie à tout le
monde c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose il y a des avec des pluies etc il
y a des communes qui rentrent deux
hectares trois hectares quatre hectares
j'en sais rien mais assurer une garantie
à tout le monde c'est faire en sorte que
aucune commune ne soit laissée au bord
du chemin d'ailleurs vous l'avez dit
avec ce système quand même assez
compliqué assez large les maires des
petites communes je reprends mon propos
sont largués et dans les mêmes experts
c'est ce qu'il faut éviter et donc il
est important d'assurer un minimum
garanti à tout le monde ça existe en
beaucoup de domaines de cette première
cause il y a le SMIC il y a le minimum
vieillesse et on parle même d'une
retraite à 1200 euros donc donner une
garantie minimum à chaque commune ça me
paraît essentiel et je suis resté merde
un petit village pendant très longtemps
on n'a pas consommé beaucoup de terrain
en fait en construction en revanche on a
pu saisir les opportunités qui nous ont
permis dans un département qui est
compliqué en terme démographique de
garder la population et de garder nos
services et notamment notre école donc
voilà ça on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler je n'y reviens pas si j'ai bien
compris le 1% vous proposez c'est 1% de
la surface urbanisée
vous me le confirmerez
sur les finances des collectivités alors
c'est vrai que les choses sont plutôt ça
apparaissent plutôt bien avec plutôt un
recul de la dette en même temps on sait
très bien que derrière des moyennes se
cachent et des disparités très très
fortes et donc il faut faire attention
au jugement comporte à travers à travers
les moyennes
sur la DGF vous l'avez rappelé 2023 320
millions
d'augmentation dans un contexte quand
même d'inflation mais une augmentation
et moi je défendais ça donc vraiment on
est en phase là-dessus une augmentation
de 320 millions ramenait une échelle de
27 milliards il faut toujours
relativiser qui a été ciblé sur les
communes les plus fragiles c'est-à-dire
celles qui bénéficiaient de la
périclation donc
voilà nous étions nombreux à partager
cette orientation et du coup ma question
c'est pour 2024 les années à venir sur
cette question de la péréquation comment
voyez-vous les choses pensez-vous qu'il
faut continuer à finalement dans une
moyenne globale de collectivité qui va
plutôt bien à privilégier l'aide aux
communes les plus fragiles un petit mot
je peux pas maintenant pêcher sur les
aménités rurales un sujet qui me tient à
cœur vous le savez sur lequel il y a eu
des avancées significatives depuis deux
trois ans et notamment cette année
pensez-vous qu'il faut aller un peu plus
loin en tous les cas si vous le français
nous serons tout à fait en face là
dessus un peu plus loin pour une
meilleure reconnaissance des aménités
rurales à travers la dotation aux
communes pour la protection de la
biodiversité qui a été créée j'avais une
question sur le fond vert mais vous y
avez parfaitement bien répondu en disant
est-ce qu'on peut imaginer qu'il sera
reconduit ça dépendra de la réussite du
fond vert 2023 j'ai bien compris mais je
ne doute pas qui réussira et puis juste
un petit mot sur les compétences
pensez-vous qu'il faut faire encore
évoluer ou adapter avec le recul que
l'on a maintenant sur les différentes
lois décentralisations et les transferts
de compétences est-ce qu'il faut faire
évoluer les partages de compétences à la
fois au niveau du bloc communal et entre
département et régions et pour tenir
compte aussi des extensions de périmètre
que l'on a vu et puis beaucoup de nos
collègues sont
sensibles et attachés à la question de
l'assainissement pensez-vous qu'il y a
des ouvertures possibles sur sur le sur
le fait de laisser au territoire en
fonction de leur spécificité le choix de
la compétence au ass
par Bernard delcro n'est pas une petite
question et ça n'est pas à marronnier
de radoteurs que sera le Sénat
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le ministre de votre
présence ce matin au sein de la
délégation moi j'avais plusieurs
questions mais je n'en poserai qu'une
puisque dans quelques minutes maintenant
j'ai une question orale en séance et je
suis au deuxième position donc je fais
un très bref ça concerne l'agenda rural
qui a été très bien accueilli à
l'origine et puis chemin faisant qui a
laissez quelques déceptions c'est
un programme un concept certains parlent
même de nébuleuses très diffus et
beaucoup autant les mers se sont très
vite appropriés les outils financiers
que cela dutr la décide et maintenant le
fond vert autant le plus un concept pour
eux sans doute parce que les il est
réparti dans différents ministères et il
est présent dans quantité de programmes
différents et ne le maîtrise pas il ne
le une
innocence in ne le sont pas appropriés
donc on arrive à l'acte 2 de l'acéta
gendar rural je sais que vous y
travaillez avec les associations
notamment l'association des maires ou de
France est-ce que vous envisagez un
document du même type où est-ce que vous
irez vers une plus grande lisibilité
pour l'avenir
monsieur le ministre peut-être si tu
dois partir peut-on répondre d'abord à
Jean-Marie maison et ensuite il y a donc
Guy benaroche Céline Brulin Patricia
chez linger et Jean-Pierre Corbisez
voilà chers amis
se transforme pas au citrouille parce
qu'on est je remercie
de sénateur Bernard buis de considérer
que finalement j'ai déjà globalement
répondu à sa question
quelques quelques éléments d'abord vous
avez raison de dire et je termine donc
je commence par Jean-Marie maison compte
tenu de la question qui arrive d'abord
vous avez raison de dire que
il y a sans doute des marges
pour que cet agenda rural soit
mieux connu
je pense qu'il est totalement nécessaire
aujourd'hui y compris parce que
ce sont les communes rurales qui sont
finalement aussi en point sur la
transition écologique contenue
indépendamment d'un discours qu'on
entend parfois en particulier parce que
le stockage du carbone la capacité de
résilience elle repose aussi sur ses
transitions que c'est là où on a
potentiellement les tensions les plus
fortes
liées à des modifications de
motorisation qui supposent des
investissements qui n'existent pas
toujours et où il n'y a pas
d'alternative à la voiture ou alors des
alternatives qui sont écologiquement des
impasses ce qui imaginez qu'on fera
passer des transports en commun en
milieu rural on va pas s'amuser à mettre
des rails dans un certain nombre de
secteurs qui finirait par avoir un coût
en termes d'artificialisation ou
d'impact qui serait négatifs et qu'un
bus avec moins de 6 personnes dedans ça
consomme plus qu'une voiture
individuelle et donc qu'à la fin quand
je conjugue le service et la réalité il
faut que je sois capable de trouver les
ajustements qui vont bien d'où le
leasing social pour la voiture
électrique à moins de 100 euros d'où
l'été ad d'où la perspective de regarder
comment on a des alternatives cet agenda
rural
que ce soit pour faire des territoires
ruraux
des fers de lance de la transition
écologique pour renforcer l'attractivité
pour améliorer la vie des habitants ou
pour accompagner les élus ça reste vrai
on a besoin d'une nouvelle phase et ça
va avec d'ailleurs la réflexion aussi
sur les zones de revitalisation rurales
ça me permet de faire le lien avec
Bernard delcro et la manière plus large
dont on propose un pacte de confiance à
la ruralité et dans lequel on envoie des
messages parce qu'il y a un ressenti
mais il y a aussi des choses qui
relèvent du du réel dans un sentiment
parfois d'abandon de ces de ces
territoires
je maintiens totalement ce que je dis
sur le sur la garantie je ne considère
pas que la garantie d'un hectare ce soit
un bon signal la taille moyenne des
communes dans ce pays elle varie de 0
habitants à un million 8
la façon dont le texte en première
intention est conçu c'est un hectare
pour tout le monde quel que soit sa
taille je plaide pour que la garantie
rurale s'applique aux communes rurales
et que on lit que la garantie de la
porte cassée qui rentre dans cette
catégorie est-ce que c'est le nombre
d'habitants est-ce que c'est la faible
densité on peut discuter j'aurais plutôt
tendance à partir de la faible densité
en considérant que c'est le moyen de
tenir compte de ce que la MRF indique
et à partir du moment où je fais un
pourcentage d'identique à tout le monde
c'est juste parce que ça veut dire
qu'une commune de 2000 habitants
bénéficiera d'un peu plus qu'une commune
de 200 habitants et de ce point de vue
je pense qu'il y a une forme de justice
plus grande que dans une règle
identique c'est moins marketing mais
c'est plus juste et je vous le dise en
tout cas de façon très simple il n'y
aura pas de CMP conclusive à la fin sur
une règle d'un hectare compte tenu de ce
que seront les positions d'entrée donc
où nous souhaitons améliorer
conjointement le texte on est dans des
postures à quelques mois de déchéance
électorales mais je pense que ce serait
dommage et pas la hauteur alors qu'il y
a une une capacité à bouger
les impacts en termes de surface ils
sont les mêmes
si je donne un nectar à tout le monde ça
fait 35 500 hectares
si je donne 1%, ça fait 34 500 hectares
si je réserve ce bénéfice aux communes
peu denses ça fait 17000 c'est à dire à
peu près la moitié
et donc on sera sur à la fin une règle
qui consistera en volume être sur un
volume comparable mais par la partie de
la même manière
et il ne faut pas que dans la discussion
sur le plancher ou la garantie
on ne crée un monstre qui consisterait à
penser que c'est comme une là n'aurait
le droit à rien de plus parce que la
vérité c'est qu'on revient à nos sujets
de territorialisation de stradettes et
trajectoire et il est souhaitable que
dans des quantités d'endroits les
perspectives et les trajectoires soient
significativement plus élevés que cette
garantie y compris parce qu'il y a une
attractivité naturelle qu'il faut pas
masquer après
plusieurs plusieurs sujets
sur les aménités rurales
je vous rappelle que ça fait deux années
consécutives que la dotation
Biodiversité pour les communes a été
doublée
je sais pas si on conservera un rythme
qui consiste à faire fois deux chaque
année mais c'est quand même un effort
qui a tendance
dans la vie c'est un effort qui a
tendance et réelle
moi je continue de penser que
c'est malgré tout un bon axe et plus
largement je vous le dis dans les sujets
de l'année 2023 pas seulement
collectivités territoriale mais pour le
pays et la planification écologique on a
la question de la biodiversité après la
COP 15 en décembre le sujet c'est la
stratégie nationale de biodiversité et
c'est son financement
aujourd'hui la biodiversité les pays
comment pour partie via les agences de
l'eau
alors qu'on sait qu'on a des besoins en
termes de dépenses liées à la situation
hydrique que nous connaissons qui vont
nécessiter de renforcer ses moyens
budgétaires
j'ai finalisé avec Bérengère Couillard
un plomb haut d'une cinquantaine de
mesures
qui attend les derniers arbitrages et
qui va de l'encadrement des forages
jusqu'à la réutilisation des eaux usées
la question des eaux grises la question
de la lutte contre les gaspillages et
les trous dans les réseaux la
sécurisation de l'eau potable etc
et dans tout ça puisque tout est dans
tout on aura ce type de sujet mais on
parlera également
du sujet qui n'est pas un marronnier qui
je sais agite un certain nombre d'entre
vous
700 communes ont connu des difficultés
dernier
c'est le chiffre définitif
la proportion de celle qui gère la
compétence seul
démontre que ce système n'est pas
tenable
l'intercommunalisation de la gestion de
l'eau
va devenir une question de santé
publique et de sécurisation
il y a une corrélation une simultanéité
quand on superpose les cartes entre les
gestions solitaires et les défauts
d'approvisionnement
je dirais même plus dans un certain
nombre de cas
de faible prix au mètre cube sont
parfois l'indice d'un
sous-investissement et d'un niveau de
fuite particulièrement élevé
et
on peut difficilement expliquer que
l'eau est un sujet crucial est considéré
que sur un thème comme celui-là il faut
pas assurer un minimum d'interconnexion
de sécurité
de rebouclage qui nous permettent à un
moment d'être plus résilient dans le
dispositif et je vous assure que quand
vous regardez ça je n'aurai pas la main
qui tremble pour expliquer que on ne
peut pas remettre en cause l'obligation
d'intercommunalisation en 2026
ça ne passe pas la rampe d'un examen
objectif de ce que seront les risques
véritablement en termes de rupture
d'approvisionnement d'eau potable dans
certains de secteurs
donc je sais les attentes et de
réflexion qui a là-dessus je suis pas
pour rigidifier le dispositif
on expliquant qu'il faut des syndicats
départementaux etc je crois la nécessité
d'avoir des cartes qui tiennent compte
de la réalité mais je pense qu'il faut
qu'on ne peut pas avoir de commune seule
situation très très très exceptionnelle
contenu de leur situation géographique
mais ça n'est pas un bon message c'est
pas souhaitable et c'est pas le sens de
l'histoire compte tenu des difficultés
dans lesquelles nous allons globalement
en termes de stress hydrique je vais
très vite puisque je crois qu'il y a
encore beaucoup de questions et que le
temps se raccourci mais je ne doute pas
qu'on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
votre dernière sujet c'est sur la
péréquation et la DGF bon c'est trop
vaste pour le faire en deux minutes la
question qui se pose à un moment c'est
on a tellement de couches
je dirais
archéologique dans la DGF avec des bouts
de trucs on a des références pour une
partie des dotations qui dépendent par
exemple de la longueur de voirie alors
qu'on a fait des transferts à
l'intercommunalité on a parfois des
références qui s'appuient sur la taxe
d'habitation pour être capable d'aller
calculer telle ou tel dispositif donc on
a une forme de toilettage contenu de
bout de réforme qui ont été décidées qui
supposerait un moment de se poser et
d'avoir une forme de réflexion plus
large
sur la manière dont on accompagne
voilà ce que je peux dire et la question
de la péréquation elle doit s'intégrer
là-dedans ce qui est certain c'est qu'on
a des écarts de richesse entre les
collectivités qui font que la
péréquation elle est objectivement juste
ensuite est-ce qu'elle est au bon niveau
est-ce qu'elle va trop vite pas assez
vite comment elle se met mais qui est de
la perquation il en est des
collectivités comme il en est des
individus la redistribution des
richesses en veillant un minimum
d'équité renforce la cohésion des
territoires
merci monsieur je veux pas en rajouter
mais quand même monsieur le mini vous
êtes trop faim trop intelligent et vous
avez trop de respect pour cette maison
pour éventuellement mais j'ai sans doute
très mal compris
interprété ce que nous n'avons jamais
dit au Sénat quand nous défendons
un regard sur l'eau et l'assainissement
il n'a jamais été question pour nous de
d'affirmer et de prétendre que c'est
parce qu'on est seul que l'eau est mieux
gérée jamais sauf monsieur le ministre
et là vous vous ne pouvez pas ne pas
être d'accord avec moi parce que ce sont
les l'eau ne coule pas selon des
périmètres administratifs mais l'eau
coule selon la nature et selon des
bassins versants donc nous ce que nous
disons oui au fait qu'il faut
effectivement être un échelle de
pertinence avec la gravité des choses
mais si on peut sortir de la rigidité
miraculeuse française qui consiste à
mettre des gens dans une boîte quand la
bois de leur va pas voilà mais je serai
pas plus longue on va en reparler c'est
un sucre
et ben voilà et ben ça me réjouit alors
j'arrête de parler parce que mes
collègues vont m'en vouloir parce que
vous passionnez vous passionnez tout le
monde chers amis
le temps nous est compté si je puis dire
Guy benarange Céline Brunin Patricia
chininger Jean-Pierre corbiset Franck
motoger voilà
donc allons-y les amis Guy benaroche
merci tout le roi de la sobriété donc si
tu peux nous le prouver ce matin merci
je vais être décroissant dans mes
paroles donc
sur le ministre parmi les éléments
d'incertitude dans l'utilisation des
forfaits globalement d'ailleurs pour
toutes les communes dans l'utilisation
de tous les fonds qui pourraient être
qui pour arriver de l'État c'est la
capacité des collectivités en fait à
porter la transition en matière de
ressources humaines et denzinori donc ma
question je vais la faire très
brièvement en fait dans le Forex dans
l'utilisation du Forever
ne s'est-il pas pertinent de permettre
aucune d'utiliser une partie des faux
verts pour des frais d'acide URI et de
fonctionnement
c'est le cas auteur de 15%
. merci présidente monsieur le ministre
vous m'inquiétez quand vous dites que
l'ensemble des crédits du filet de
sécurité risque de pas être consommé
et je suis très inquiète enfin pas très
inquiète je mesure qu'elle va être la
réaction des communes notamment qui vont
apprendre ça
on est un certain nombre pour ne pas
dire tous ici à avoir alerté sur la
complexité de ce dispositif
sur le fait que peut-être dans ce
contexte que vous évoquez des communes
vont être amenées à rembourser les
acomptes qui leur ont été versés enfin
je pense qu'on va au devant d'un fort
mécontentement sur ce sujet et ça me
confirme dans l'idée que peut-être le
plus simple ce serait de revenir pour
toutes les collectivités qu'il souhaite
à la possibilité d'accéder au tarif
réglementé de l'énergie enfin tarif
réglementé de vente des tarifs qui
devraient être mieux
adosser au coût réel de production et de
commercialisation plutôt que des
dispositifs comme ça avec des critères
dont on savait depuis le début qu'il
serait très à mettre en oeuvre et que il
y aurait des trous dans la raquette et
des gens qui passeraient entre les
mailles du filet
et d'ailleurs s'il reste des crédits moi
je vous alerte sur un sujet dans le
sujet c'est qu'il y a un certain nombre
de collectivités de communes notamment
qui ont dû renouveler leur contrat au
plus haut des hausses d'énergie à
l'automne en gros et qui voit
aujourd'hui qu'elles ont contracté des
contrats avec ce niveau de de dépenses
qui aujourd'hui a un peu diminué même
pas mal diminué et donc est-ce qu'il n'y
a pas à réfléchir à les aider à
renégocier ces contrats pour qu'elle
revienne au prix plus actuel deuxième
question très vite madame la Présidente
sur le fond vert j'entends vous dites on
n'a pas augmenté la DGF au niveau de
l'inflation mais il y a le fond vert et
je reprends ce qu'on dit un certain
nombre de collègues oui mais le fond
vert il a quand même un certain nombre
de critères qui ne permettent pas de
rentrer toutes les opérations que les
collectivités voudraient réaliser et
donc
on a là encore un aspect de un peu de
recul de l'autonomie des collectivités à
travers ce fond et je pense que même si
on peut se réjouir que ce fond soit
aujourd'hui à disposition ça ne doit pas
définitivement enterré l'idée que la DGF
doit être indexée sur l'inflation mais
sur le filet de sécurité je joue la
transparence la plus totale avec vous je
vous dis pas que les sommes sont pas
atteintes je vous dis quand je regarde
aujourd'hui ce que sont les chiffres je
n'ai pas un niveau de recours à la
hauteur de ce qu'on imaginait mais si je
jouais à faire la même chose sur le
chèque carburant
il y a 10 millions de foyers qui sont
éligibles on a moins de 5 millions pour
le moment qu'ils l'ont demandé
donc quelle est la part de non recours
potentiels et de gens qui ne connaissent
pas le dispositif et quelle est la part
des quarts d'estimation entre ce qu'on
pensait être le besoin est-ce que sera
la réalité pourquoi je prends les
devants en disant que si c'est le cas de
manière à éviter une éviction de crédit
pour reprendre des termes européens ça
vaut le coup de se dire qu'un budget
constant il y a peut-être des
compléments qu'on peut apporter aux
collectivités plutôt que ça retombe dans
le pot commun vous voyez je vais assez
loin dans ce que je dis et dans la
manière dont je le dis
mais à ce stade c'est une forme d'alerte
en considérant qu'on est tous très
attentif à la situation des
collectivités et qu'on souhaite qu'elle
soit capable d'investir et de porter les
enjeux de solidarité transition à
l'échelle de notre pays
ça n'est pas une manière de vous dire
que les sommes seront pas au rendez-vous
c'est une façon de s'assurer qu'elles
vont le rester je précise là-dessus sur
le fond vert
encore une fois il y avait rien on
ajoute 2 milliards
laissons-nous un peu de temps on a fait
un truc hyper large on a supprimé on a
été à rebours de ce qui se fait depuis
des années dans le fait d'aller mettre
des appels à projets des appels à
manifestation d'intérêt on a fait aussi
simple que possible on a imaginé 14
portes d'entrée on n'est jamais que le 9
février donc je souhaite juste que on se
laisse un peu de temps qu'on soit aussi
capable de faire un bilan et qu'on
regarde pour les années qui viennent
comme on a vocation la rangée mais je
pense que c'est le la bonne la bonne
façon de procéder avec une large
possibilité pour les élus de l'utiliser
et on me dit que dans un certain nombre
d'endroits en fait c'est l'inverse qui
se passe on met au titre du fond vert
des crédits qui étaient fléchés vers de
la 2tr ou de la des cils
pour libérer les enveloppes qui ensuite
peuvent être utilisées sur d'autres
critères j'attends là aussi d'avoir un
début de retour mais j'ai eu des
premiers retours en disant on commence
par prendre les dossiers des cils des
etr déposés et tous ceux qui sont
éligibles au fond vert on va les mettre
dessus comme ça on récupérera des
crédits pour autre chose donc c'est ça
globalement la dynamique que je retiens
sur les prix de l'énergie
là le sujet il est un tout petit peu
plus complexe c'est à dire que vous
savez très bien qu'il y a une part qui
relève de droits européens qui relèvent
de droit à la concurrence et l'urgence
là-dessus c'est ce qui se passe à
l'échelle européenne c'est d'abord la
réforme du marché européen de
l'électricité et de l'absurdité qui se
consiste à payer le kilowatt sur la base
de ce qui est financé dans le cadre du
gaz et ça c'est pas ce gouvernement ou
le précédent c'est 20 ans de politique
globale dans lequel on a pour des
raisons de convergence européenne mis en
place un dispositif dont on imaginait
pas qu'il aurait cette conséquence
contenu de ce qui était notre mix
énergétique et on a des enjeux qui sont
considérables à plein d'échelle c'est
évidemment de faire en sorte de
retrouver notre part de nucléaire parce
que une partie aussi des surcoûts est
liée à cet indisponibilité c'est de le
conforter dans les années qui viennent
pour conserver une indépendance et une
possibilité d'avoir une énergie qui soit
décarbonée qui soit pilotable et c'est
la progression de nos énergies
renouvelables pour sortir du fossile
parce que sinon de toute façon quel que
soit les mécanismes qu'on mettra en
place les tendances réussir qu'on
connaît on les retrouvera avec en prime
les dégâts sur la planète donc on a une
convergence de vue et j'allais dire que
la question des tarifs même si elle est
brûlante elle est secondaire par rapport
à leur mécanisme le mécanisme fixation
des prix puisque le premier sujet c'est
que même si je bougeais les règles
si on veut pas vendre de l'énergie à
perte il faut aussi qu'on soit capable
de réformer le dispositif
merci Monsieur le Ministre alors si
jamais nous n'avions pas le temps de
poser toutes les questions que je vous
propose c'est que dont les transmetions
au ministre qui sera ravi
d'y répondre et puis il y a des sujets
qu'on n'a pas abordés pour lesquels ils
vous aurez droit à une seconde chance en
venant nous voir Patricia merci Patricia
le ministre on parle beaucoup de
sobriété énergétiques qui demandent
beaucoup d'investissement dans les
communes et les collectivités
territoriales ont parfois plusieurs
responsabilités moi je sais que vous ne
travaillez pas seul et que vous devez
travailler avec d'autres ministères par
exemple lors des fermetures de piscine
l'interrogation me vient comment dans le
dans les mois les années à venir comment
les jeunes enfants vont pouvoir faire
avoir des cours de natation alors qu'ils
étaient déjà privés pendant le covid il
y a un retard qui se fait les écoles
mais pas que nous avons aussi les
gendarmerie où il y a un part des
collectivités territoriales ou les
bâtiments ne sont pas isolés où il y a
besoin de d'investissement mais aussi
les maisons de retraite et les hôpitaux
comment le bilan va être fait dans les
territoires et surtout les priorités moi
j'ai l'impression comme mes collègues on
rencontre beaucoup de municipalités qui
sont en train de vouloir faire partout
le Club House mais en se précipitant
c'est pas toujours la bonne solution
donc qui à un moment donné sera là pour
dire ben non on va gérer sur les
territoires et je vois que les petites
communes ont beaucoup de volonté mais
elles n'ont pas les moyens alors à un
moment donné comment est-ce qu'on fait
le bilan un état des lieux comment on
avance et un calendrier parce que c'est
vrai que aujourd'hui on est au début
d'une grande histoire mais comment on
avance dans cette grande histoire et
avec le partenariat de plusieurs min
parce que ça ne touche pas que votre
ministère et et surtout derrière il y a
des hommes et des femmes qui ont besoin
d'aussi d'une écoute
madame la sénatrice sillingée
il y a un enjeu considérable
plus de 300 millions de mètres carrés de
bâtiments publics
appartenant aux collectivités locales et
un mètre carré sur deux c'est du
scolaire
là où vous avez raison c'est qu'il faut
pas se dire bon allez je rénove
il faut d'abord savoir par où on
commence donc avoir une cartographie de
ses propres passoires et des endroits on
a les meilleurs retours sur
investissement et il faut parfois se
demander si on doit conserver dans le
patrimoine public certains bâtiments qui
sont parfois
inutilisés et sous-utilisés et donc qui
se traduisent par des dépenses de
fonctionnement et par le fait qu'il
pourrait avoir un autre usage
et donc il y a une sorte de
planification à conduire qui est parfois
complexe contenu des moyens humains dont
on dispose dans des communes de petites
tailles ça c'est tout à fait exact
j'attends de la loi sur le tir
financement qui sera voté la semaine
prochaine d'abord qu'on est un cadre et
un moyen alternatif a de la dépense
budgétaire
dans les dispositifs d'évaluation qui
sont prévus et qui sont plutôt renforcés
par les amendements déposés par le par
le Sénat on aura la capacité finalement
d'avoir une idée de ce qu'on peut
attendre en termes de performance
énergétique
et au travers de cette performance
énergétique on saura quelle est la durée
d'amortissement et l'intérêt qu'il y a à
faire les choses ça suppose de
l'ingénierie
on revient notre sujet
notre idée c'est sans doute de regarder
comment dans le bâti scolaire on
pourrait confier une sorte
de mission un peu nationale à la banque
des territoires pour proposer un
dispositif parce que il y a des écoles
dans presque toutes les communes on
parle de 50 millions de mètres carrés et
de plus de 44000 écoles publiques donc
on est une maille nationale avec une
espèce de référentiel là-dessus pour un
dispositif qui concerne toute la France
ça nous semblerait pas stupide mais
après il y a une telle hétérogénéité de
situation que ce sera pas la bonne
réponse et que je crois l’ingénierie à
l'appui locale je pense que des agences
de proximité je pense que des CM je
pense que des Epl peuvent jouer ce rôle
je pense dire qu'ils peuvent le jouer
dans l'ingénierie mais dans le portage
foncier si j'étais mère c'est ce que je
conduisais moi je m'appuierais sur mes
SPL vraisemblablement pour conduire ces
opérations tir financement et pour être
capable de faire le truc en inaous avec
une analyse et je pense que la première
chose que je déciderai c'est que
l'intercommunalité se propose de le
financer et de le calculer pour les
communes
en laissant la main ensuite aux communes
sur la gestion d'école mais en proposant
de centraliser les diagnostics
énergétiques et l'accompagnement et
c'est un amendement spécifique déposé
par le Sénat de prévoir que le tiers
financeur peut être l'intercommunalité
pour le compte des communes je pense que
c'était vraiment un excellent moyen
c'est pas une contrainte c'est pas une
obligation c'est pas un transfert c'est
une option et une possibilité qui de mon
point de vue va dans le bon sens c'est
un élément de réponse partielle mais
néanmoins qui me semble souhaitable dans
le fond vert et je termine là dessus
on indique qu'il est souhaitable
d'attendre 40% de baisse c'est aussi un
moyen d'expliquer que on n'a pas
vocation à les financer de la rénovation
qui a un impact marginal et qu'il faut
quand même qu'il y ait un effet de
levier sur le climat qui soit
relativement important même si dans les
faits les consignes passées au préfet
c'est de l'apprécier sous cet angle de
l'efficacité pas d'aller mesurer le
avant après de manière extrêmement
précise au
kilowatt-heure près ou au kilo de gaz à
effet de serre à éviter
alors
chers collègues là c'est du haut vol
Jean-Pierre Corbusier Franck montoger
Anne Catherine loyer monsieur le
ministre on ne se quitte plus hier on a
évoqué la PPL concernant le tiers
financement pour le favoriser les
travaux de rénovation énergétique pour
les collectivités et un de mes collègues
a dit oui mais aujourd'hui les communes
ne peuvent plus mettre les 20%
obligatoires dans le cadre des
investissements publics c'est la règle
or notre Présidente il y a quelques
années à sortir un excellent texte c'est
d'ailleurs un pléonasme qui rappelle
qu'effectivement la participation
minimale doit être d'ouvrage est de 20%
du montant total sauf dérogation du
représentant de l'État dans le
département c'est à dire le préfet le
préfet peut aller au-delà des 80% de
subventions si l'estime que la
participation minimale est
disproportionnée au vu de la capacité
financière du maître d'ouvrage or les
préfets sont très frileux d'appliquer ce
texte qui est dans le Code général des
collectivités territoriales
est-ce que vous pourriez vous engager à
rappeler au préfet cette règle dans la
mesure où une fois qu'on a additionné
toutes les subventions des départements
région FDE fédère Adem si la subvention
de l'État de TR ou autre on
l'additionnait toutes les autres si on
dépasse 80%, ils ont le droit de le
faire pourriez-vous vous engager
effectivement à ce que les préfets dans
nos départements rappelle on leur
rappelle cette règle qui permettrait
ainsi aux petites communes rurales et
d'autres qui n'ont pas qui n'ont plus de
moyens d'aller au-delà des 80% de
subvention de façon à ce qu'elles
puissent passer au vu de l'urgence
climatique à ces travaux de rénovation
énergétiques
oui
je vais le faire vous avez raison la
réflexion hier avait du sens
fondamentalement je pense que c'est
souhaitable de le dire d'abord parce que
ça existe
philosophiquement je pense que le zéro
reste à charger et pas bon parce qu'il
est quand même toujours souhaitable qui
est une petite parc qui assure que la
maîtrise vérifie qu'on gaspille pas
d'argent public voilà mais qu'en
revanche on se fixe pas sur un 80 que
dans certains cas à 97 à 88 un 92 père
permettent d'aller débloquer tel ou tel
élément ça ne me pose pas de difficulté
je remercie monsieur le ministre
pas abusé
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le ministre pour vous expliquer
mes présentations vous avez fait
allusion en fait un sujet qui nous
préoccupe dans cette délégation
régulièrement c'est celui de la fabrique
de la de la loi
moi je pense comme comme vous que on est
dans une citation en particulier par
rapport aux
âmes qui est un exemple typique
ou le comment
presque sur le sur le quoi sur
l'objectif politique que l'on se fixe
donc moi je la question que je veux vous
poser à la lumière de la façon dont se
déroule la question du zan dans les
échanges entre gouvernement et
Parlement à en particulier
ne croyez-vous pas que on devrait
dans les études d'impact
se poser la question justement du
comment de la faisabilité des objectifs
que l'on se donne ça nous permettrait
probablement de légiférer
en pleine connaissance de cause et de
cause des difficultés que pose
effectivement l'objectif politique qu'on
peut se qu'on peut se donner avec le zan
on est typiquement typiquement dans ce
dans ce dans ce cas de figure donc moi
j'en appelle peut-être partageurez-vous
à ce que les études d'impact soit plus
large et se pose finalement la question
de la faisabilité de l'objectif
politique que l'on se fixe et je trouve
que aujourd'hui on ne le fait pas
suffisamment et que ça nuit finalement à
l'efficacité
de la relation gouvernement Parlement et
à l'efficacité de l'acte législatif le
deuxième point il est plus anecdotique
mais il me paraît très important par
rapport à ce que vous avez dit vous avez
parlé de la
alors taxation je sais pas si c'est le
mot des effets domaines d'aubaine induit
sur le foncier par le la question du zan
cette question là elle se pose aussi par
rapport à d'autres projets je vais vous
en donner un qui parlera tout le monde
c'est celui des lignes TGV dès lors que
vous avez une ligne TGV qui arrive sur
un territoire les populations modestes
qui veulent acquérir du foncier pour se
loger etc de venir sont obligés de
partir sur le rural et souvent le rural
profond sans que le mot soit des
obligeants à l'égard de quiconque et
avec les difficultés souvent que ces
territoires Roro ont pour accueillir
parfois dans de bonnes conditions les
populations concernées donc est-ce que
cette idée qui me paraît bonne a priori
peut-être pas facile à mettre en œuvre
vous comptez l'élargir à d'autres sujets
à caractère inflationniste notamment sur
le pli du foncier merci
il me semble que tenir compte des études
d'impact et déjà inscrit dans un certain
nombre de textes donc forcément ce soit
suivi des faits et parfois la brièveté
avec lesquels on transmet les textes
en complexes y compris l'application de
ces dispositions autour desquelles tout
le monde se retrouve
je vais faire un pas de plus en vous
disant que ce que je pousse à l'heure
actuelle c'est une étude d'impact
climatique
je pense que nous devrions avoir la
maturité pas seulement de discuter en
euros mais de discuter en carbone je
pense que nous devrions être capable de
regarder sur un projet à la fois ce
qu'est son impact budgétaire et ça
commence à le faire de plus en plus mais
aussi ceux qui sont impact carbone parce
qu'il y a parfois des bonnes idées
autour desquels tout le monde peut se
retrouver mais qui aurait un impact
totalement marginal sur les émissions en
provoquant des débats considérables et
des sentiments de frustration de
certaines populations et à l'inverse il
y a parfois des idées qui produisaient
énormément de gains climatiques et sans
qu'on soit capable à ce stade de les
documenter
et donc on les investit pas suffisamment
le meilleur exemple étant le covoiturage
qui est certainement l'investissement en
termes de soutien qui a l'effet
climatique le plus élevé pour
l'investissement le plus faible on n'a
pas besoin d'apporter des voitures de
l'extérieur ça ne dégrade pas notre
déficit commercial on n'a pas besoin
d'apporter des bornes de recharge et à
chaque fois que je mets deux
automobilistes dans une voiture je
divise par deux un bilan carbone
et c'est souple ça permet de se faire
quelque soit le territoire sur lequel on
se retrouve et quel que soit sa densité
avec aujourd'hui en plus des systèmes de
mise en relation qui permettent
d'avancer je donne cet exemple je
pourrais en donner d'autres donc c'est
dire si j'adhère entre guillemets à
votre idée
et puis je mets une deuxième pièce dans
la machine la question
de la taxation de l'artificialisation
c'est en fait une invitation à penser la
transition écologique d'un point de vue
fiscal
à quel moment je commence à faire en
sorte que mes impôts reflètent ou des
signaux prix reflètent une incitation à
être vertueux
et derrière votre question sur le TGV
etc d'abord il y a des mécanismes qui
sont parfois à la main des collectivités
locales vous faites un tramway sur un
territoire vous pouvez faire une taxe
d'aménagement majorée qui est doublé sur
le secteur qui va faire l'objet ensuite
de la gentrification ou de l'évolution
urbaine vous pouvez le justifier à
proximité d'une opération de
renouvellement urbain c'est à la main
des collectivités locales et vous pouvez
doubler les niveaux de taxe de manière à
récupérer des crédits sur les promoteurs
qui vont aller s'installer dans tel ou
tel endroit pour participer au
financement parce que il bénéficie
finalement de retomber positif de
l'investissement que vous avez fait
ce qu'il faut un nouveau mécanisme dans
le cadre des LGV
je ne sais pas je pense que de manière
plus large on a des réflexions fiscales
multiples à conduire
si je veux une agriculture à laquelle on
n'exige pas des rendements il faut qu'on
pense la question de la fiscalité des
terrains agricoles qui sont élevés et
qui poussent du coup à avoir un niveau
de revenus qui ensuite amène à se poser
la question de la persistance
d'un certain niveau on a on a plein de
questions et puis il y a quand même un
éléphant dans la pièce 40 milliards dans
le budget de l'État sont issus de la
fiscalité sur les carburants au fur et à
mesure qu'on va faire en sorte de rendre
électrique le parc il y a donc une
opération de défiscalisation en
parallèle qui se conduit alors même que
ces crédits servent à financer nos
investissements ferroviaires et d'autres
types du même donc
voilà il y a une réforme fiscale globale
qui est à penser en lien avec la
transition écologique
alors la dernière n'est pas la moindre
mais très rapide je vous promets même
présidente monsieur le ministre merci
beaucoup en fait moi c'est juste pour
revenir sur le sujet de la consigne pour
recyclage des bouteilles plastiques est
un sujet particulierement sensible
auquel sont attentives nos collectivités
puisque ça impacte forcément la gestion
globale des déchets donc où sommes-nous
sur ce sujet monsieur le ministre merci
bon je voudrais de façon très brève
juste vous dire que conformément
d'ailleurs à ce qui était dans la loi
Haget
la concertation est lancée pour savoir
si la matière ou pas faire une consigne
à compter du 1er juillet de cette année
puisque c'est la date théorique à
laquelle on pourra faire les choses je
vous rappelle que demain
je fais un effet mérite aujourd'hui
c'est l'anniversaire de Thierry cosyk
que je salue et demain ce sera
l'anniversaire de la loi au GECK de la
loi à Jacques pardon cette loi Jacques
faitra ces trois ans ce qui est
sensiblement moins que l'âge du sénateur
de la Sarthe mais ce qui sera néanmoins
un bilan d'étape sur un peu plus des
1000 premiers jours de cette loi de
lutte contre le gaspillage
la consigne c'est un vrai sujet
pas simple
parce que c'est aujourd'hui
sincèrement un domaine dans lequel on
est quand même pas les meilleurs on
n'est pas bon à l'échelle européenne on
est à moins de 60% entre guillemets de
prélèvement de nos bouteilles plastiques
et de recyclage quand certains de nos
voisins du Nord ont déjà dépassé les 80
% et on a des objectifs ambitieux
qu'on pour le moment que nous
n'atteinions pas et on sent pas la
volonté locale parfois de l'atteindre on
n'a pas les mécanismes problèmes de la
consigne c'est que aujourd'hui
c'est même bouteilles en plastique elle
représente pour les collectivités
locales une ressource
dans un contexte où les finances
autour des déchets se tendent puisque la
progression de la TGAP pour faire en
sorte d'avoir des gestes qui soient plus
vertueux a tendance à augmenter donc si
on vous baisse vos recettes et qu'on
vous augmente vos dépenses j'ai pas
besoin de vous faire de dessin sur les
moyens de ton dispose et au moment où on
oblige sur les biais
la concertation avec les collectivités
locales elle va être cruciale parce que
de toute façon y compris demain allez
imaginer des dispositifs de consignes ça
veut dire des endroits physiques dans
lesquels vous les récupérez recommencez
que c'est globalement sur leur domicile
qu'on a les marges de progression qui
sont les plus fortes ça veut dire des
dispositifs de centre-ville
donc
est-ce qu'il faut un dispositif unique
où je fais de la consigne partout et où
je retire entre guillemets ce gisement
collectivité territoriale
est-ce qu'il faut un dispositif dans
lequel les collectivités peuvent
elles-mêmes entre guillemets bénéficier
du dispositif et où elle deviennent
acteurs parce que c'est pas parce que je
fais une consigne que ça ne bénéficie
qu'à une filière est-ce qu'il y a une
forme de partage en tenant compte du
gisement actuel
les questions sont sur la table mais on
fera pas l'économie d'un dispositif qui
nous permet de tendre vers les 90% de
recyclage des bouteilles en plastique
parce que là aussi on peut pas
documenter ce que sont des conséquences
de ce plastique qui se disséminent dans
les écosystèmes et qui a des
conséquences pour notre santé et de
l'autre
rester dans un statu quo qui est qui est
coupable donc
c'est une vraie concertation madame la
sénatrice non mais au sens où on a
vraiment besoin de discuter avec tout le
monde de ce qu'est le bon système
exactement et donc maintenant le moment
c'est on ouvre le dossier et on trouve
une solution
merci monsieur le ministre je veux
vraiment au nom de mes collègues à mon
père vous remercier pour le débordement
auquel je vous ai parlé ici voilà sur
l'horaire merci beaucoup je voudrais
dire aux collègues cet après-midi en
réponse à certaines de leurs questions
nous avons un débat extrêmement
important sur les services déconcentrés
de l'État à la recherche de l'État dans
les territoires et je pense que voilà
c'est en cohérence et que nos
préoccupations il y a un sujet qui me
tient à cœur et au coeur de tous dont
nous n'avons pas parlé mais nous en
reparlerons ce sont les communes
nouvelles et enfin monsieur le ministre
je vous informe et vous le savez déjà
nous en avons parlé que le 16 mars dans
cette honorable maison ici même sans
doute se tiendront les états généraux de
la simplification en écho à la question
de notre collègue Franck montoger je
participais ce matin avec Alain Lambert
un émission sur Public Sénat nous on
guérir
on dit halte au harcèlement sur les
normes et nous pensons d'une manière
très sérieuse que nous pouvons ensemble
c'est-à-dire l'État le cnen les
associations des lieux et les
parlementaires vrai pour reconstruire
des lois plus sobres plus simples qui
soit moins coûteuse et plus aisée à
mettre en oeuvre donc nous avons
adressons le président du Sénat adressé
une invitation extrêmement officielle à
madame la Première ministre et nous ne
voulons pas faire que parler mais nous
allons proposer à la signature du
gouvernement à la signature du CNN et du
Parlement une charte d'engagement qui ne
nécessite aucune modification de la loi
mais qui permettrait de mesurer si la
loi qui est proposée elle est vraiment
nécessaire
est-ce qu'il y a pas moyen de faire sans
que nous mettions aussi des sortes de
dispositions guillotines qui nous oblige
à évaluer expérimenté enfin voilà la
vertu
n'attend pas que les vœux de très bonne
année donc monsieur mini je ne doute pas
que vous serez passionné parce que nous
faisons et que le gouvernement sera
sincèrement c'est pas du tout un piège
mais moi je crois qu'il est temps qu'on
soit là vraiment somme et frugal parce
que c'est l'efficacité en tout cas
milles merci Monsieur le minis et à
bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures sur
le
zin je me réjouis
et quelques autres sujets et je voudrais
simplement vous remercier et vous dire
que vous devez à la présidente Gatel le
fait que j'ai pu faire quelques
prolongations puisque nous avions
initialement un temps d'échange en
tête-à-tête qu'elle m'avait demandé
qu'elle a accepté de rendre à cette
commission pour aller au bout des
questions que vous posiez c'est dire si
la présidente ne s'applique pas
elle-même
les efforts qu'elle demande
elle en prend plus que sa part et je
voulais quand même le signaler parce que
c'est une élégance rare mais qui ne
surprendra pas ce qui connaissent ceux
qui connaissent